it's so great to be back on campus I was
reflecting yesterday that it has been
indeed nine years since i took that the
design class that embrace came out of so
I'm feeling extra old today so I'd like
you guys to go through an exercise with
me before I begin please close your eyes
and hold out your hands in front of you
and imagine what you could place inside
your hands an apple maybe your keys now
open your eyes what about a life what
you see here is a premature baby he
looks like he's resting peacefully when
in fact he's struggling to stay alive
because he can't regulate his own body
temperature sadly there are millions of
babies like this born every year around
the world in fact 15 million preterm and
underway babies are born annually three
million babies die in the first 28 days
of their life at six babies every minute
one of the biggest problems these babies
face is staying warm and that is the
primary function of an incubator but
incubators are expensive they cost
twenty thousand dollars upwards they
require a constant supply of electricity
they're difficult to operate so you're
not going to find them in rural areas
where many of these babies are dying in
2007 while I was doing my MBA here at
Stanford I took a class at the design
school that would completely change my
life many of you may be familiar with it
but designed for extreme affordability
brings together students of all the
different graduate programs with the
goal of creating low-cost technologies
for people living on less than a dollar
a day the challenge posed to my team at
the time was to build a baby incubator
that cost less than 1 percent of the
cost of a traditional incubator which in
the u.s. is about twenty thousand
dollars so the first thing we did was to
go on the ground to places like Nepal
and Uganda and thistle is what we would
often see so this is a hospital neonatal
intensive care unit that's completely
overcrowded every baby in here is in
need of incubation and then you have a
donated incubator sitting in the corner
of the room that's empty why there's no
electricity to power it no one's been
trained on how to use it if
heartbreaks there are no spare parts for
replacement so even when these
incubators are free when they're donated
they're not usable because of all these
systemic issues instead people use
solutions like this these are old space
heaters used to warm babies you put your
hand in front of one of these and you'll
immediately feel it starting to burn or
light bulbs these are the most common
solution in India where forty percent of
all the world's premature babies are
born but in every clinic I've visited
you hear stories of light bulbs
shattering over these babies because of
problems with these circuits so
completely unsafe and ineffective
solutions out there from there we travel
to the villages and that's where I truly
began to understand the problem this is
sujatha this is one of the first woman I
met a village in South India sujatha
gave birth to her baby two months
prematurely she took her baby to a
village doctor who advised her to go to
a city hospital so her baby can be
placed in an incubator but that Hospital
was over four hours away and she didn't
have the money to get there and so her
baby died and since then I've heard
dozens of similar stories but it was
based on stories like this that we
realized what was needed was not just a
lower-cost version of what exists today
we needed something that could function
without a constant supply of electricity
that would be easy enough for a mother
or Midwife or a healthcare worker in a
village setting to use so coming back to
Stanford we went to the drawing board we
wanted something super intuitive to use
so we created a sleeping bag design
these are literally our first sketches
of the product on the back of a napkin
and then we thought what could maintain
heat at a constant temperature without
the need for electricity we went back to
high school physics to the concept that
when a material changes phases let's say
from a solid to a liquid or a liquid to
a solid it does so at one constant
temperature what if we could find a
material that melted a human body
temperature and then put enough of that
substance in but that melting period
took place over hours at a time we
didn't know what the material was so we
prototyped with the closest thing we
could find this is butter in Ziploc bags
made quite a mess at the d.school from
there we went to a Salvation Army and we
bought everything bay
related we could find and literally
started duct taping our first prototypes
together so if you can see here our
first prototype had a tube going down
the side of the sleeping bag where you
would pour boiling water and that would
melt the phase change material and then
we showed this to some people and they
said to us it's probably not a good idea
to put boiling water right next to a
baby's head we quickly scrap that and
moved on to our next prototype here we
realize that babies in these countries
often don't wear diapers so we needed
something a material that was waterproof
and really easy to wipe down those are
the materials were identified here and
then with those early prototypes we went
back to India and we show that to
mothers to doctors to health care
workers and with their feedback we
continue to iterate on the design we
realize the importance of sterility
because these are all reusable we didn't
want babies to cross infect each other
if they were sick so we ended up
creating the sleeping bag out of one
entire piece of fabric for their limited
seams on the inside where dirt can
collect here doctors requested a clear
viewing window so they could observe the
baby's breathing and color more easily
and then this is one of my favorite
stories so on the wax pouch there is a
temperature indicator it's a liquid
crystal display that changes color
according to the temperature so you know
when it's too hot or too cold and as we
showed this to mothers and villages we
heard something very unusual they would
say to us we don't trust Western
medicine if you gave me a dosage of
medicine for my baby I would cut it in
half because it's too strong so if you
told me to keep this at 37 degrees
Celsius or 98 degrees Fahrenheit I'd
keep it at a little less than that
because that's probably too warm so that
led to a very important design decision
to make it a binary happy face frowning
face instead of a numeric scale and I
think that's really the key to great
design is empathy and all of these
nuances that are culturally appropriate
when we needed to do more testing we use
our own family members this is my nephew
that I stuffed into one of the early
prototypes
and so it was in this way that we tested
and retested hundreds of times over the
course of several years until we were
finally ready to launch the product in
2011 I've got it with me here today so
this is the embrace warmer as you can
see it looks like a little sleeping bag
made out of waterproof materials you've
got the clear viewing window here and in
the back we've got this pouch of wax
that can met be melted either with
boiling water or with a short burst of
electricity for places that do have
intermittent access to electricity and
once melted it stays at the exact same
temperature for up to eight hours at a
stretch and this can be reheated
thousands of times so you put it into a
little pocket in the back and it creates
a warm micro environment for the baby
I'll passes around so you guys can play
around with it a bit so I still remember
in 2011 as we're launching the product
and those weeks leading up to our
product launch everything that could
have possibly gone wrong went wrong the
electricity in our manufacturing
facility went out in the most critical
moments a part of our product got stuck
in customs and they wouldn't release it
the wash tags are sewn incorrectly but
somehow we managed to get that first
product ready to ship to our first
customer and then on the way to that
doctor's office we got a flat tire so
the whole team jumped oh we piled into
this auto rickshaw that you see here
Henry delivered our first product and I
always tell the story because it's so
representative to me of what
entrepreneurship is all about which is
doing whatever it takes to get past the
obstacles that come in your way and
finally reach that end goal and here's
our very first customer the most
exciting part of this journey by far has
been getting this product into the hands
and the families and the babies who need
it the most and we have been so lucky to
get the support from people of all
different walks of life we're really
rallied behind us too to help make an
impact with this product which really
led me to believe this quote from Paulo
Coelho that I love he says when you
truly believe something
the universe will conspire to help you
achieve it a few years ago we were
invited to present our work to President
Obama the White House and I got great
visibility for our efforts we presented
a commitment at the clinton global
initiative as well and formed some great
partnerships through that 2014 Beyonce
he made a donation to us a surprise
donation that got our products in 29
countries across sub-saharan Africa and
so with the help of all of these people
to date we have been able to help over
200,000 babies the product is now in 20
countries and i'd like to share just a
few of the stories of the babies we've
helped so this is one of my all-time
favorite stories i always tell this one
this is nathan about four years ago we
started working with an orphanage in
beijing a day after we delivered our
product they called us telling us they
had found a two-pound baby that was
abandoned on a street in central China
they brought Nathan in kept him in the
warmer for about 30 days it was a very
scary period for all of us we weren't
sure if he was going to survive or not
seven months later I went to visit the
orphanage and I got to hold Nathan in my
arms he's just vibrant interactive
little boy and was a very very special
experience an orphanage told me this was
the first time a baby of this size had
ever survived there a few months after
this we got an email from a family in
Chicago saying they had adopted this
little boy and we're traveling to
Beijing that summer to bring him home so
here Nathan is with his new family and
when he turned to we sent him a warm
work for his birthday week until he's
outgrown if I just a little bit in the
next story I'm going to show a short
video this is anasema from Uganda yes
yeah there we go
you
ngong is nec- nana addo a condom wear a
mini merengue burton deauxma
and my new next aboard aboard and fight
everybody
nah saravana vivere hombres no vara vara
trana to KUKA at everton on brains iana
1.5 muah erina 0.77 city when I saravana
ranga very bottom in yo windows antenna
began de la medicina amoeba gamma sigma
sent it rangamati know me and my brother
Madrid Oregon government no co-op what I
one man's and NAFA
mano a mano eravamo we're extending
specialty and Indiana kumara when I come
up with you on sanam Singh I'm embrace
room
ibis aw boo banga man can
empty suomi ganda chuba ranibennur da
Booma buena guatemala a charity to get
up
Batman digas algo para maana ano ponder
okay
banga banta know when they're comin ome
Trueba i'm ganna quangha boom boom bah
aquamarine acqualina embrace but not too
many unfortunate acquire embrace attend
ameri- he was an embrace aquarium
program
I'm gay an ambassador to attempt a
sender ammu Uganda walk ova mama bhanja
Gansey ivana Bob evita gay boom boom
so it's just a few more pictures of the
product being used around the world this
is our twins in Uganda while using the
embrace warmer in a few months later
these are some images of the product
being used across sub-saharan Africa so
it's been incredibly rewarding and
exciting to be a part of this effort and
to create this type of impact but I
would be lying if I were to tell you
that it was all roses and flowers and
that we didn't face some extreme
challenges along the way it's always
wonderful to have a vision of what you
want to do but as Mike Tyson says
everyone has a plan until they get
punched in the mouth this has happened
to us repeatedly and I could tell you
about our challenges for days but I'll
tell you about one pivotal moment for us
I really kind of redefine the business
and taught me a lot about life as well
so in 2014 I'd lived in India for four
years and moved back to the US and at
that time we'd been working on a global
distribution and financing deal with a
major medical device company so I'd been
working on this deal day and night for
almost a year at that point and then
about a week away from signing the deal
we found out that this company let go of
their healthcare CEO who was the main
advocate for the deal and they pulled
the plug on our financing we had seven
days of cash left in the bank and I was
completely devastated and no idea what
we were going to do all of us that we
were going to have to shut down the
company and then a miracle happened nine
months prior to that I had gone to the
World Economic Forum at Davos and one
morning I went to a meditation session
which may be five out of 3,000 people
showed up for and I happened to sit next
to Marc Benioff who is the co-founder
and CEO of Salesforce mark and I started
talking after the meditation session and
I shared with him my work and embrace
coincidentally he was about to make a
donation to create the preterm birth
initiative at UCSF and partnership with
the Gates Foundation so if there
anything in the world that would make me
believe in serendipity it was the
universe seating me next to this man I
kept in touch with mark and when this
crisis hit I sent him an urgent email
telling him what had happened asking for
his help I'm John Hennessy was one of
our advisors also reached out to mark
asking for his help and a few days later
he wrote back generously agreeing to
fund the company so I'm just so indebted
to mark for saving the company we would
have to have had to close our doors if
it weren't for that and it was a really
pitiful pivotal experience in a number
of different ways but one of the things
it forced me to do at that point was to
take a step back and really really ate
our strategy you know at the time we
were selling our product primarily to
the Indian government and working with
government contracts can be extremely
painful you don't know when the
contracts are going to come through when
you're going to get paid it wasn't
leading to a sustainable business model
at the same time it started to look at
models like TOMS shoes and Warby Parker
and the team was thinking what if we
could leverage our technology and create
a product for the US market and then use
the the profits from that to fund the
expansion of the embrace warmers in
developing countries and so that led to
the birth of our newest initiative which
is called little Lotus and I was just
laughing to myself as I was preparing
this presentation because this was
coincidental but a lotus the
representation of a lotus it's a flower
that comes from you know these dark and
muddy waters and turns into something
beautiful some form all the chaos that
we experienced we came up with this
really cool product and what it is it's
a line of baby products for the US
market so sleeping bag swaddles and
blankets that have a technology akin to
the embrace warmers the fabric of these
products is lined with microns of wax so
this was first used in NASA space suits
and what it does it serves to absorb or
release heat to keep babies at an ideal
skin temperature helping them to sleep
better so our informal studies have
shown that baby sleep on average an hour
longer with our product versus existing
products because of less temperature
fluctuations but there
real impetus for doing this was to
implement a Tom shoes inspired
one-to-one model so for every little
lotus that we sell here in the US we
help to save a life in a developing
country with the embrace former I think
the ethos behind doing this as I came
back to the US and started doing
research I would talk to lots of parents
and moms in particular I'd often hear
them say to me you know when I became a
mother for the first time I felt an
instant camaraderie with every mother
other mother in the world and if I saw a
baby in need I would do anything to help
that child so we really wanted to create
a global community of parents helping
other parents another cool aspect of the
little Lotus you'll see you notice that
their handprints all over the front
panel of the product and that comes from
an artwork called touch our future so I
collaborated with another Stanford alum
drew kataoka on this initiative she's an
amazing artist and her concept was to
collect the hand traces of mothers and
babies from all over the world from 14
countries many of whom have been
directly helped by the embrace warmers
in addition to that we got the hand
traces of the Dalai Lama and about 20
Nobel Peace Prize laureates and a bunch
of Hollywood celebrities as well so it's
been a really fun way for people to
literally lend their hand to this cause
and with the 141 model our hope is that
over the next few years we're able to
reach a million babies with the embrace
warmers and truly get this product into
the hands of every baby and every family
who needs it so that is my story that is
the last ten years of my life and this
is where we're at today and I thought
I'd end by just sharing a few of the key
lessons that I've learned in this
journey so the first lesson is the lead
with the why got this from Simon's I
next Ted top even watched it I highly
recommend it why do you do what you do
and how does this is align with your own
purpose and your own values and this is
so much more important than what you do
or how you do it i think in being really
rooted in your purpose and being clear
about that why it will get you through
your toughest moments and get you
through all those obstacles you're going
to face
and at the same time it will allow you
to inspire others and rally people
behind your cause so give a lot of
thought to why it is you want to do the
things you do my second lesson here from
Winston Churchill who said success is
not final failure is not fatal it is the
courage to continue that counts and I
have a picture of me surfing here
because this is a sport I picked up
about a year and a half ago and I've
become completely obsessed with and one
of the things about surfing it's so
humbling because most of the time I'm
not on my board i'm falling off my board
and having to find the courage to get
back on and paddle back out for the next
wave and to me this is the most
important trait of being an entrepreneur
is persistence and tenacity because you
will inevitably fail over and over again
and you need to have the courage and
that persistence to get back out there
learn from your mistakes and try again
the other related thing I've learned
from surfing and the ocean is this idea
of impermanence you know everything in
this world is constantly changing and
nothing teaches you that more than being
in the ocean where your conditions are
changing minute to minute and what
that's taught me about is this concept
of non-attachment to not be attached to
anything including and outcomes I think
it had become so attached to this end
outcome for embrace that the thought of
the company shutting down in that story
I told you really threaten my own sense
of identity and what I learned from that
process is that we are not defined by
our successes or failures we are defined
by our values and by the journey that we
take so as cliche as it sounds but the
journey is truly more important than the
destination and make sure you're having
fun in that journey every step of the
way and my last lesson here is to choose
to see the world through the lens of
beauty because we get to choose the
perspective by which we see the world
after living in India for a few years I
could see myself becoming jaded and
really pessimistic I was dealing with
some of the most vulnerable populations
in the world and saw so many sad things
I was worth
a very corrupt and broken system and
then at some point I caught myself and I
realized that for every horrible thing
that I saw I saw something equally as
beautiful all of the wonderful people
who come together to help us in this
cause all the noble doctors i met who
stayed up all night in these villages to
see patients the most beautiful thing I
got to see in my work was a love a
parent has for their child it's a purest
and most selfless form of love in the
world and I realized that a mother no
matter how poor or uneducated or
impoverished will do anything to save
her child and that's the beauty i got to
see every day in my work so i encourage
you to see the world through the lens of
beauty because that will give you the
optimism to keep changing the world and
i wanted to leave you with one last
thought so this is the milan cathedral
the great cathedrals of Europe were
built over centuries this one the
construction began in 1385 wasn't
finished until nineteen sixty-five what
that meant is oftentimes of people who
spend their whole lives working on these
cathedrals never live to see the fruits
of their labor nor did their children
nor did their grandchildren so why did
they dedicate themselves so tirelessly
to building these monuments i believe it
was because they believed in a cause
that was far greater than themselves so
as each of you to think about what is
the cathedral that you want to build and
what is the legacy that you want to
leave my Cathedral is a place where no
baby dies from being cold it's a place
where every parent is empowered to save
their child and it's a place where the
brightest minds come together to change
the world for the better one baby step
at a time thank you
so would you take some questions I'm
solutely you said that um I think
beyonce gave a donation but your company
also was funded so can you clarify
whether it's a non-profit or a
for-profit company yeah there are
reasons behind yep so we started as a
non-profit as a 501 C 3 in 2008 that's
when we first started out in 2011 we
actually spun out a for-profit arms the
company and the idea was that the
for-profit would sell the product to
governments in emerging markets and then
pay a royalty fee to the nonprofit we
really hope that that would create a
self-sustaining model at the time a lot
of impact investors were coming into
play as well encouraging us to explore a
for-profit route it was just an easier
way to raise capital so the real reason
for doing it was so we could leverage
both philanthropic capital to donate the
product to the poorest places as well as
private capital to do the more
capital-intensive parts of our work yes
you speak to sort of the design
constraints or some of the thinking
behind going down this approach versus
something like neo nature which is
basically you know an incubator run by a
car battery and a couple of Toyota
headlights yeah no that was an
alternative approach some tokens sure so
I think it goes yes I so the question
was the thinking behind going behind
this design approach and creating
something that could be used kind of in
a home setting as opposed to there's
another product out there that's used
out of spare car parts for example that
looks more like a traditional incubator
so I think for us what the are aha
moment was the story I mentioned where
we went into the villages and we
realized that we could design for a big
city hospital setting but that wasn't
where the real problem was and we really
wanted to create a product that could
sit in a village setting that would
prior very minimal training because
that's where we felt the root of the
problem was
I know I don't know I noticed that
please you seem to be working with
people from the region so are they
becoming part of your team how is the
dynamics when you move from the US and
QT places where you didn't have actual
partners yeah how do you work with these
people are they your partners are they
just helping you can you talk about this
thing I sure so in India we you know we
were situated there for the first four
years who really built up a local team
and hired people on the ground as well
as worked with partners both in
government and nonprofit and so on in
other countries that we work and we do
work through a partnership model so we
work with the millennium villages across
sub-saharan Africa we work with a
non-profit in Afghanistan for example
we've just started a project with one in
Nepal so our thinking there is that we
really rely on the expertise of our
local partners for already working on
newborn care issues who can then easily
integrate the embrace warmers into those
programs so it's very unusual that we
will have our own stuff on the ground we
really train our local partners to
implement the product i have this is so
much easier to use and so much cheaper
than driving solutions in adult
countries their reason why all right
yeah enter into this market into
developed countries yeah like say in the
US okay okay so the question is why
can't the product entered the US health
care system it definitely can in fact we
have done a first study at Lucile
Packard showing that you can mean babies
off of incubators and put them in this
device instead it just requires a
different Road and Curt in terms of
getting an FDA approval for example
putting our resources there and then
really changing behavior here and that's
a whole nother set of issues because
although kind of intellectually it seems
like a much easier product to use
changing doctors behaviors and changing
systems around that can be very
challenging and so for the time being
we've decided to focus the warmers on
emerging markets and really have the
consumer product here that allows us to
fund that yeah Jennifer Internet
very critical that's pretty cool so the
question was how did we get people over
the their criticism of the product you
know it I don't know if the I've used
the word criticism but it did require us
to show doctors for example clinical
studies and show the evidence that this
works as well as the standard of care in
these settings and then have enough
experience there that with influencers
especially in key opinion leaders in
these markets that they could influence
others and really use that word of mouth
and and the trust in the product and the
company to get it out there further and
so I think that would and I think it was
also helpful for people to see that we
had really situated ourselves locally
that we were catering towards the market
it wasn't just something we had
developed here at Stanford and try to
implant in these countries what we had
really taken into account all of the
systemic issues that you know led to the
product being more appropriate it took
the first well the development of the
product took about two years in the
clinical setting fully two and a half
years and then it's been you know that
was 2011 so it's been five or six years
since then yeah and it's still it's
still ongoing we've like--we're barely
at the tip of the iceberg here in terms
of the impact we hope to create it's
been much more challenging and stick in
a lot more time than we anticipated yes
wonderful presentation to question what
cost how do you pick societies of two to
participate in the program to baby
shouts of you you reach out to that
apenas yeah you know you know there's a
whole bunch of colleges and
anthropological issues so how do you
choose sure so the question was what is
the cost per warmer and how do we decide
to go into certain communities so the
cost performer is about two hundred
dollars per each warmer I'm that
includes the sleeping bag the wax insert
that you saw on a separate heating unit
and the product is entirely reusable and
so we estimate the cost of saving a
single life with the product including
being logistics everything else is
roughly about ten dollars per life saved
and in terms of going into communities
we really I think a lot of it depends on
the partners you'll be able to find
because with even though the great
technology you really need to have find
effective partners who can implement you
can do the training who can do the data
collection and monitoring and so we
really rely on this wonderful network of
NGOs on the ground that are specifically
focused on newborn care that that's
already a part of the work that they're
doing and then we can kind of slot this
technology in with India though we just
chose to move to India right away purely
because of the numbers you know as I
said India has forty percent of all the
world's premature babies and so it was a
no-brainer that that's where we were
going to start what do you see what
would your talk be in eight years from
now how happens between now and that
that's a great question so I think for
us it's a couple of things one is our
our hope is to really get this into the
hands of every baby who needs to make it
universally available and adopted
technology the other thing those when we
would love to work on new technologies
and the dream was always how do we
create a platform by which we introduce
other technologies that reduce infant
deaths around the world if you look at
the Millennium Development Goals
reducing infant mortality was one of
them and that was the one we made the
least progress on over a decade of time
and so it's always ironic to me that we
sit here in Silicon Valley with all of
this high-tech everything around us and
yet so many babies are dying every
single day you know how could that be
and so we are currently working on for
example integrating sensors into the
product and trying to do a remote
monitoring and eventually leveraging AI
we'd love to do predictive Diagnostics
yeah
so this product has requires like a
really deep knowledge of biology and
like healthcare systems and I was
wondering what kind of techniques or
advice you had for people who want to
develop products and fields that they're
not very knowledgeable and experienced
yeah that's a great question gives in it
then we had three co-founders and none
of us had any experience in material
science or medical experience and we
came up with this and I think the key is
really just around yourself with a group
of advisors who do have that depth of
knowledge we formed a wonderful advice
we both bored both here locally as well
as one in India and they really led both
the clinical studies and collecting all
of that scientific data around the
product and also with this there was no
kind of set regulations on how to do
this you know we didn't fit neatly into
a regulatory system and so they provided
that deep guidance as well and then once
we move to India you know we have this
team of people were really enthusiastic
and passionate you could see things or
different lens it was important to
counterbalance that with people who have
deep experience of things like creating
a rigorous quality control system and no
manufacturing so I say surround yourself
with with expert see their advisors or
people that you bring internally into
your organization yeah so this story is
so impressive and it's one that's used
often to celebrate the design thinking
process and you guys were in the first
class that can go second graph design
for extreme affordability are there
other examples that have come out of
that program in that process that are
equally inspiring absolutely delight is
a company that I really look up to so
they make very very low-cost LEDs and
they came out of the exact same class
one year prior and I think they are
shipping something in the order of a
hundred thousand units a month and so in
terms of scalability and really finding
that sustainable business model in
addition to a cool technology they've
really nailed it